oui bah écoutes je voulais savoir si tu
avais envie de manger
ouais bah ouais bah je t'avoue que j'ai
assez faim là j'ai aussi envie de manger
là
je sais pas ce que tu as deux côtés mais
tu as peut-être des knacki des knacki tu
as oui ok après il faudra qu'on aura
mangé ça on pourrait aller se promener
du coup peut-être moins ça va nous faire
digérer
oui ni non
trois députés
comme vous pouvez sortir à l'extérieur
despatie ça va moi aussi je fais ça
c'est trop bizarre on est vraiment les
menant le jeu mais les photos des gens
que j'aime pourquoi je suis par contre
ça je sais pas mais on
effectivement la suite
vous savez savez quelque chose vous
savez comment je suis arrivé si cet
après midi
je suivais vénérable à en vélo vert anne
hidalgo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]